-You know, lately
I have been having a great time
watching old movies.
I especially like watching them
on the Cherished Cinema Classics
channel.
The host is super knowledgeable
and gives really interesting
introductions to the films.
Check this out.
♪♪
-Welcome back to
Cherished Cinema Classics.
I'm your host, Clyde Darwell.
Next up, from 1946,
"Passion on the Prairie."
A thrilling frontier romance
starring Van Westmore,
Constance Pigeon,
and Everett Zuker.
Though a huge box office success
in its day,
it's worth noting this film
is a product of its time.
By today's standards,
it contains
outdated insensitive portrayals
of African-Americans.
But keeping that in mind,
we hope you can look past
those flaws and enjoy
this American classic,
which I should also note is
offensive to Native Americans,
Asian Americans,
Lebanese Americans,
the Inuit,
and Estonian Americans.
But having said that,
it's a vital piece of film
history that is to be treasured.
So, sit back, relax,
and also a quick note about
the love scenes in this film.
They don't all seem entirely,
how you say, consensual.
Grabbing women and kissing them
by force, and when they resist,
slapping them was considered
romantic in the 1940s.
Now, not so much.
Nevertheless, this movie
remains a pinnacle
of Hollywood's Golden Age.
So pour yourself a tall soda
and settle in
for the splendid
three-hour spectacle,
"Passion on the Prairie."
♪♪
Wait, one more thing.
I should warn viewers sensitive
to this sort of thing,
there's a graphic whale hunt
midway through the film.
Also what some might consider
gratuitous kicking of a beagle.
Anyway, I think
that covers it all.
African-Americans,
beagle kick, consent.
Yeah, that's it.
Now let's travel back to 1946
with the historic,
incomparable
Cherished Cinema Classic
"Passion on the Prairie."
♪♪
Oh, wait, I forgot a biggie.
This movie is
super sympathetic to Nazis,
which seems really late
for 1946.
So, here we go.
Wait.
There's also a scene
where a non-binary ranch hand
is referred to by
the improper pronoun,
which actually seems way ahead
of its time.
You know what?
Let's cut out
the problematic scenes
and show only parts of the movie
that aren't offensive now.
Does that sound good?
"Passion on the Prairie."
Roll it.
♪♪
Wow. They don't make 'em
like that anymore.
Next up on
Cherished Cinema Classics,
the 1932 screwball
comedy classic
"Real Men Don't Wear Skirts."
Oh, brother. Here we go again.
♪♪
-Yeah, they're gonna have
a rough season.